wo ist dein weg
wir wissen nicht wo jahre ist sie ist
nicht hier und wir wissen auch nicht
wann sie wieder kommt du und tag ihr
habt den schlüssel jahre zeit und es
sind freunde
sie hat auch die schlüssel fürs
restaurant wir helfen uns hat das ist ja
toll himmel
ich möchte noch ein paar brötchen kaufen
kannst du mit nico könnte mir einen
gefallen tun
wir brauchen noch ein paar lebensmittel
aber ich wusste auch nicht allein lassen
weil wir können doch für euch einkaufen
gehen oder nico vielen dank dafür
bekommt ihr das nächste ist wie sonst
und könnt ihr mir noch ein hähnchen drei
gurken und tomaten mitbringen ein von
tomaten das ist aber nicht viel
schreibst du es auf nico das ist für
meinen abendbrot kannst du das bitte
noch einmal wiederholen
ein hähnchen händchen drei guten gore
und ein funk tomaten 1 50 mark land und
bund das sind 500 gramm also ein halbes
kilo
vielen dank und später dann reden wir
über deine tante okay
ja